it's a roboticist I can ask a lot of
questions when will they start serving
me breakfast so I thought the Future
Robotics would be looking more like us I
thought they would look like me so that
I built
eyes that would simulate my eyes I built
fingers that are dexterous enough to
serve me baseballs classical robots like
this are built and conventional they
based on the fixed number of joints and
actuators and this means their
functionality and shape are already
fixed at the moment of their conception
so even though this arm has really nice
thorough to even hit the tripod at the
end it's not meant for cooking your
breakfast per say it's not really
suitable for assemble eggs so this was
when I was hit by a new vision of future
robotics the transformers they drive
they run they fly all depending on ever
changing new environment and task at
hand to make this a reality
you really have to rethink how robots
are designed so imagine a robotic module
in a polygon shape and using that simple
polygon shape to reconstruct multiple
different forms to create a new form of
robot for different tasks in CG computer
graphics it's not only news it's been
done for a while and that's however most
of the movies are made but if you're
trying to make a robot that's physically
moving it's completely new story it's
completely new paradigm but you've all
done this who hasn't made a paper
airplane paper boat paper crane origami
is a versatile platform for designers
from single sheet of paper
you can make multiple shapes and if you
don't like it you unfold and fold back
again any 3d form can be made from 2d
surface by folding and this is proven
mathematically and imagine if you were
to have a intelligent sheet that can
self fold into any form it wants anytime
and that's what I've been working on and
I call this robotic origami Robo gummy
this is a first robot gummy
transformations and that was made by me
about 10 years ago from a flashing a
robot it turns into a pyramid and back
in the flat sheet and into a space
shuttle quite cute ten years later with
my group of ninja origami robotic
researchers there's about 22 of them
right now we have a new generation of
Robo commies and they're a little more
effective and they do more than that so
the new generation of origami is
actually serve a purpose for example
this one actually navigates through
different terrains autonomously so when
it's a dry and flat land it crawls and
if you need sudden a rough terrain it
starts rolling it does says it's a same
robot but depending on which terrain it
meets it activates different sequence of
actuators that's on board and once it
meets an obstacle it jumps over it it
does this by storing an energy and it
each of legs and releasing it and
calculating like a slingshot and even
does gymnastics yay
so I just showed you what a single
origami can do imagine what can they do
as a group they can join forces to
tackle more complex tasks each module
either active or passive we can assemble
them to create different shapes not only
that but controlling the folding joints
very able to create and attack different
tasks the form is making new tasks space
and this time what the most important is
the assembly you need to autonomously
find each other in the different space
attach and detach depending on the
environment and task and we can do this
now so what's next our imagination so
this is a simulation of what you can
achieve with this type of module so we
decided what we're gonna have a
four-legged crawler turning to a little
dog and making small gates with a same
module we can actually make it do
something else a manipulator a typical
classical robotic task so with a
manipulator it can pick an object of
course you can add more modules to make
them a new pair of legs longer to attack
with or pick up objects that are bigger
or smaller or even have a third arm for
a robo gummies there's no one fixed
shape nor tasks they can transform into
anything anywhere anytime so how do you
make them the biggest technical
challenge of Robo gommi is keeping them
super thin flexible but still remaining
functional they're composed of multiple
layers of circuits motors
microcontrollers and sensors all in the
single body and when we control
individual folding your joints you be
able to achieve a soft motions like that
upon your command instead of being a
single robot that is specifically made
for a single task Robo gummies are
demised to do multitask and this is
quite important for the difficult and
unique environment on the earth as well
as in space space is a perfect
environment for Robo bombers you cannot
afford to have one robot for one task
who knows how many times you the counter
in the space what you want is a single
robotic platform that can transform to
do multi task what you don't want is a
deck of thin rubber Gani modules that
can transform to do multiples of
performing tasks so here and don't take
my word for it because it's European
Space Agency and Swiss Space Center are
sponsoring this exact concept so you're
here here you see couple of images of
reconfiguration of Robo commies
exploring the foreign land above ground
on the surface as well as it digging
into surface it's not just exploration
for astronauts they need additional help
because you cannot afford to bring in
turns of there either we have to do
every tedious task they may be simple
but super interactive so you need robots
to facilitate their experiments
assisting them with a communication and
just docking on to a surfaces to be
their third arm holding different tools
but how would it be able to control Robo
gommi for example outside the space
station in this case I show a robot
gummy that's holding a space debris you
can work with your vision so that you
can control them but what would be
better is having the sensation of touch
directly transported onto the hands of
the astronauts and you would need is a
haptic device haptic interface that
recreates the sensation of touch and
using Robo commies we can do this this
is a world's smallest haptic interface
that can recreate a
sensation of touch just underneath your
fingertip we do this by moving the
rubicon ii by microscopic and
macroscopic movements at the stage and
by having this not only you'll be able
to feel how big the object is the
roundness and rate and the lines but
also the stiffness and the texture alex
has this interface just underneath his
thumb and if you were to use this with a
VR goggles and hand controllers now the
virtual reality is no longer virtual it
becomes a tangible reality the blue ball
red ball and black ball that he's
looking is no longer differentiated by
colors now is a rubber blue ball sponge
red ball and billiard black ball this is
now possible let me show you this is
really the first time this is shown live
in front of a public grand audiences so
hopefully this works so what you see
here is an atlas of anatomy and the Robo
gommi haptic interface so like all the
other reconfiguring robots in multitasks
not only it's gonna serve as a mouse but
also a haptic interface so for example
we have a white background where there's
no object that means there's no nothing
to feel so we can have very very
flexible interface now I use this as a
mouse approach a skin a muscle killer
arm so now let's feel his biceps or
shoulders so now you see how it's
different it becomes let's explore even
more let's approach the ribcage and as
soon as I move on top of the ribcage and
between the intercostal muscles which is
softer and harder I can feel the
difference of the stiffness take my word
for it so now you see it's much stiffer
in terms of the force it's giving back
to my fingertip so I showed you the the
surfaces that's not moving how about if
I were to
wrote something that moves for example
like beating heart what would I feel
this can be your beating heart this can
actually be inside your pocket while
you're shopping online now you'll be
able to feel the difference of the
sweater that you're buying how soft it
is if it's actually cashmere or not or
the bagel you're that you're trying to
buy how hard it is or how crispy it is
this is now possible the robotic
technology is advancing to be more
personalized and adaptive to adapt to
our everyday needs this unique species
of recovery robotics is actually the
platform to provide this invisible
intuitive interface to meet our exact
needs these robots will no longer look
like the characters from the movies
instead they will be whatever you want
them to be thank you
[Applause]